[Music]
these are individuals that face a deadly
journey to get here they face deadly
terrain miles and miles of jagged rocks
jagged mountains and scorpion
brown recluse spider and rattlesnake
territory they face robbery kidnapping
assault rape and murder by gangs and
cartels
[Music]
we've been out here for half an hour to
an hour and everybody's suffering I can
imagine the people that have people the
whole way to cross the salt desert I
mean we're all need walking a few miles
with two gallons of water but they do a
whole lot more so it really makes it
experience really real
[Music]
it's not political doesn't matter what
your political stance is on immigration
now you feel about immigration it's a
human rights thing it's keeping human
beings alive
[Music]
you